c'est le plus grand déploiement
militaire américain dans la caraïbe
depuis l'invasion du panama en 1989 et
l'arrestation du président noriega pour
narcotrafic la flottille va se diriger
vers le sud à proximité des côtes du
venezuela alors que l'attention des
gouvernements et des nations est
concentré sur le court aux navires us il
y à une menace grandissante que les
cartels et d'autres acteurs et ses
rondes exploiter la situation pour leurs
propres gains nous ne pouvons pas
laisser faire nous ne laisserons jamais
faire aujourd'hui
les etats unis annoncent des opérations
antidrogue renforcer sur le continent
sud américain
nous déployons des destroyers et un
navire de combat avions hélicoptères de
la marine des navires de la garde
côtière et des avions de surveillance de
la force aérienne doublant ainsi nos
capacités dans la région un déploiement
qui pose question alors que le cours aux
navires us fait des ravages aux états
unis sans mandat de l'onu
mais soutenu par 22 pays alliés de
donald trump
il intervient surtout quelques jours
après l'offre d'une récompense pouvant
atteindre 15 millions de dollars pour
toute information permettant d'arrêter
le président vénézuélien nicolás maduro
inculpé pour narco terrorisme par la
justice américaine
des accusations sans preuve et rejetée
par les autorités vénézuéliennes
qualifiant l'attitude étasunienne de
nouvelles formes de coup d'état après
l'échec juan why do autoproclamé
président vénézuélien
avec le soutien de la communauté
internationale j'ai l'obligation de
sensibiliser l'opinion publique
nationale et internationale et de nous
préparer dans les prochaines heures
j'ai ordonné dans le cadre de
l'opération bouclier bolivarien de
mobiliser des pièces darty
il pourrait être prêt pour la lutte pour
la paix cessez le feu cessez le feu
passons à un accord humanitaire des
manoeuvres militaires américaines qui
ressemble à une déclaration de guerre
alors que les nations unies des
organisations humanitaires demandent la
suspension des sanctions contre les pays
comme le venezuela et cuba pendant la
bordée